My name is Abbie Vandivere
Princeton University Class of 2001
the Department of Art and Archaeology
Program 2 in the Visual Arts.
I initially wanted to be a dentist.
In my freshman and sophomore year,
I took all of the science classes in
order to prepare for dental school.
It was in my sophomore year that I decided
that I wanted to major in art alongside
these pre-med classes.
As part of a course I had to take, we got
to go around the Princeton University
art museum and find out what each of the
people who worked there did, so we
met with the registrars, the curators.
We also went up to the conservation studio
and when I walked into that room and saw
these paintings being restored by
Norman Muller, I thought, "Wow, this
combination of art and science is perfect
for me." And that day, I called my mother
up and said, "I'm going to be a paintings
conservator. Sorry, I'm not going to be a
dentist anymore."
For my junior project I combined the
sciences and the arts by making a series
of paintings based on view through a
microscope, and for my senior thesis
I developed this combination of science
and art further by making a whole series
of paintings, drawings, and works in
different media based on X-rays.
And I also worked at the museum for a year
after I graduated. I went for a three-year
post-graduate program at the Courtauld
Institute of Art in London for art
conservation school. After that I moved to
the Netherlands. I worked for ten years as
a freelancer working in different museums.
I did research on early Netherlandish
painting, and I got my Ph.D in 2013.
Since 2015, I've been working here in the
Mauritshuis in the Hague as a paintings
conservator. It is a small but beautiful
collection with some of the best examples
of Dutch Golden Age art, including
Vermeer's "Girl With a Pearl Earring."
I am also a coordinator and lecturer of
a new master's program in technical art
history at the University of Amsterdam.
In what little spare time I have, I play
roller derby. I play for the Amsterdam
Derby Dames, and at the moment also for
the Dutch National Team. I played rugby
when I was at Princeton and the
combination of hard hitting and fast
skating I find really enjoyable.
Every conservation treatment that I do
starts out with a thorough technical
examination where we look at the works
using different types of light: normal
light, ultraviolet rays, infrared light,
and then looking at the painting under the
microscope to find out as much as
possible about the painting technique.
This still-life by Pieter Claesz shows a
skull and a stack of books and other
objects related to life slipping away, and
I'm partway through varnish removal, and
you can see that the varnish is a little
bit yellow, and by removing it and
replacing it with a translucent varnish
that it will really regain some of its
depths and color.
In addition to treating and restoring
paintings, I do a lot of research about
painting technique. A painting hanging
right now in an exhibition at the
Mauritshuis is a painting of a goddess
and it is a very rare example of a
painting on gold leather. And I got to
examine this painting when it came up to
the studio before the exhibition, and at
the end of the day, I decided to take an
X-ray of it to see if it would yield any
interesting results, and we came up with a
fantastic discovery that the whole gold
background would have had these stamped
punched decorations that would have made
the whole background glitter and shimmer
in the candlelight, but has now been
covered up in the centuries since.
So what I call the "Leather Lady" has gone
from a piece that was hanging downstairs
in the storage facility to something that
scholars and researchers are really
interested in, and these are the types of
discoveries that make my work so exciting.
I go through this process of investigation
and I really feel a closeness, both to the
work itself and to the artist that created
it. By looking at these brushstrokes very
carefully I can kind of get into the mind
of how the artist worked, what brushes he
might have used, how his paint might have
behaved as he applied it, and because
these treatments may take several months,
by the end of this process I have a
real attachment to these paintings.
Works I've treated in the past, I look at
with great pride as I see them hanging on
the walls of a museum.